oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne peux pas attendre pour en parler
ça fait déjà quelques jours que j'ai
trouvé cette info sur le net
il faut qu'on en parle je ne peux pas
attendre de faire un trois théories star
wars 8 m'a réellement ou perturbées avec
la mort de snow que je suis totalement
perdu face à ce dernier jusqu'à même
nier sa propre mort cependant il est
temps de mettre cartes sur table et
s'orienter vers la vérité snoeck et le
suprême leader dirigeants du premier
ordre et le maître de kay lorraine
malheureusement à mon plus grand
désarroi star wars 8 ne nous a rien
dévoiler de plus à part le véritable
visage de snacks orgueilleux puissant et
imbu de lui même
cependant un livre officiel est sorti
sur ce dernier donc cannon ce livre
c'est aulas jedis visuel dictionary
écrit par pablo hidalgo et que
pouvons-nous apprendre dedans dans les
grandes lignes
snow qui est très liée au côté obscur
mais n'est pas un site qui ont
définitivement disparu quand vador fut
tué par anakin il était le dernier site
nous sommes d'accord là dessus les sites
et les jedi n'existe plus avec luc le
dernier des jedi qui est maintenant
parti cependant une chose m'intrigue
énormément il est dit dans les livres
que je cite il n'est pas un site cette
lignée millénaire qui s'étend de dark
bane au dernier site dark vador a cessé
d'exister quand vador est mort en tuant
son mentor dark sidious
l'accomplissement d'une ancienne
prophétie prédisait la fin des sites
mais pas celle de l'obscurité
ce livre est semblablement cannon
puisqu'il est officiel il est même écrit
par pablo hidalgo
néanmoins il est mentionné le nom de
dark bayne l'un des plus grands sites de
l'histoire mais qui fait partie de
l'univers legends pablo hidalgo malgré
sa carrière travaille aujourd'hui avec
disney puisque star wars est racheté par
ce dernier
il est chargé de la cohérence entre
toutes les oeuvres dans l'univers
officielle donc ce qui est cannon cela
veut donc dire d'après moi que disney
n'ignore pas totalement l'univers étendu
mais ce n'est qu'une supposition le
livre est après tout certifié lucasfilm
et non disney bref l'équilibré été
restaurée mais la nature fait bien les
choses
les sites ont disparu mais pas
l'obscurité comme il est expliqué dans
le huit
la lumière a besoin de l'obscurité et
inversement
la prophétie d'anakin ne s'arrêter qu'au
côté obscur concernant les sites pour
ceux qui n'auraient pas compris mais
aussi les jedi snoeck est donc un grand
adepte du côté obscur profondément lié à
ce dernier
je le comparerais souvent un seigneur
sith de par sa puissance sa maîtrise le
fait qu'il soit le leader et m cai
lorraine mais évidemment elle n'a jamais
été un et c'est enfin confirmé choses
intéressantes ce nom vous est un
véritable culte à dark vador jusqu'à
même posséder une bague récupérer dans
le château de dark vador lui-même sur
mustafar on comprend mieux sa réaction
face à kei lorraine totalement déchiré
d'une épave adore tu n'es qu'un enfant
avec un masque snop fantasmer sur la
ressemblance entre ben solo et son grand
père après tout ils sont parenté on peut
donc comprendre et cela semblait évident
dans l'opus 8 que cas il aurait n'était
qu'un pantin le jouet de snow qu'il
voyait comme vador imaginez un père par
exemple qui a toujours voulu un garçon
mais qui a eu une fille à la naissance
il lui donne des jouets de garçons la
vie comme un garçon né ce n'est pas
forcément sa nature et chassez le
naturel et il revient vite au galop faye
lorraine n'est pas vador et ne le sera
jamais le fait que cai lorraine soit en
extase
face à ce que son grand père a accompli
à crois tu es le fantasme de snobs
d'ailleurs
façon ils les mêmes dit dans le livre
snoeck attire accueil lorraine et le
corrompt pas car il voyait en lui son
grand père enfin une chose très
intrigante est mentionné dans le star
wars insider magazine officiellement
distribuée par lucasfilm donc
normalement cannon snoeck posséder un
second apprentis malheureusement on nous
sommes coupés entre deux directions
le terme cache et pas mal employées par
certains mais cela veut donc dire que
cet apprenti est tapi dans l'ombre
durant les événements de star wars 7 et
star wars 8 la traduction serait plutôt
que snow qui a eu un autre apprenti donc
au passé snoeck est vieux il a du vécu
ce nombreuses cicatrices et sa maîtrise
en témoigne que pouvons-nous argumenté
là dessus star wars et insider magazine
est normalement cannon donc snow qui a
bel et bien eu un autre apprenti
certainement à van khai lorraine est ce
que cela pourrait être une piste pour
l'histoire de star wars 9
eh bien oui totalement et lorraine
trahissent noc et prend le pouvoir pour
prendre sa place
cependant il est réellement déchiré
émotionnellement depuis la mort d'anne
solo son père et aussi via les échanges
avec ray disney doit savoir que cette
révélation est importante je pourrais
imaginer que cet apprenti va faire
surface dans le prochain opus
tout le monde le pense qu'il pourrait
défier cas et lorraine pour prendre la
place de suprême leader j'avais
finalement un peu raison au final je
savais que ce ne pouvait pas partir
comme ça et au final il pourrait revenir
par le biais de ses apprentis formés
auparavant cependant nous ne savons rien
ce dernier et il semble avoir été formé
avant key lorraine alors pourquoi
n'est-il pas là aujourd'hui
pourquoi n'at-on pas entendu parler de
lui avant est il mort est ce lui qui a
fait ses cicatrices à snacks avant de
s'éclipser un peu comme maul avec
palpatine et savage at il aussi trahi
snoeck pourquoi cette absence durant ces
années malheureusement
ce magazine est peut-être présent
seulement pour rajouter du contenu sur
stocks et que cet apprenti ne sera
peut-être jamais dévoilées dans les
films
enfin voila je suis content d'avoir
enfin des vérités sur stocks et je
tenais réellement parler avec vous et
l'analyser j'espère que cette vidéo vous
aura plu
je ne sais pas quand la prochaine vidéo
sur star wars sortira pour ceux qui
demanderont car je n'ai pas envie de me
forcer à en parler juste pour vous
produire des vidéos
quand j'aurai des choses à dire vous en
faites pas une vidéo sera là n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus à me suivre
sur twitter et que le 'lion' alors soit
avec vous c'était argot rock
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]